an ultimate solution to a lot of the
problems that you and I agree face
America it has to come from cultural and
religious revival and government can't
like will that into being articles like
don't be fooled by America's flattening
curve no one deserves to die of Kovan
nineteen in jail and Trump why waste a
crisis cover the New York Times's pages
it's no surprise than one of America's
most well known media outlets leans to
the left but a few writers for that
fabled newspaper are on the right
voicing their opinion on The Times as
pages Ross Douthat is one of these few
and has been with the paper for the last
11 years he's made a career of sharing
conservative thought in liberal circles
back in the day Ross ran his high school
newspaper and founded an underground
paper with none other than Michael
Barbara hosted the successful podcast at
The Daily as a Harvard student he edited
the campuses conservative newspaper and
wrote for the Harvard Crimson and after
graduating rose through the ranks at the
Atlantic to be their senior editor he's
now published five books his latest is
the decadent society how we became the
victims of our own success and twice a
week he writes in New York Times column
covering topics like the pandemic and
the will of God our liberals against
marriage what will happen to
conservative Catholicism the age of
American despair often exploring
conservatism in the 21st century in our
conversation Ross tells me what it's
like to be a conservative working at the
New York Times his thoughts on adapting
conservative policies for populism and
his warnings of America's future in the
midst of stagnation and decadence
[Music]
welcome to the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special joining us today is Ross Douthat
just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions with Ross near the end
of the show but the only way to get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member so head on over to
Daley wire.com
become a member you will have access to
all of the full conversations with every
one of our awesome guests before we get
started I want to take a moment to give
a shout out to all of our advertising
partners who help make this show
possible honestly without them we
couldn't keep the show going and without
you patronizing those advertising
partners they couldn't keep our show
going so we really appreciate you
continuing to do business with our
advertisers we're all gonna get through
this together and we'll continue to
bring you information and content that
you want let's talk about the reality
you are online now more than ever
hackers have all the time in the world
to go after your information it is
really important to have a VPN now is
basically heaven for a hacker so you
really should be disguising all your
online information expressvpn is great
because it's not like all these other
free VPN protectors you find online
Express VPN will not log your data
there's a lot of really cheap or free
VPNs that make money by selling your
data to ad companies expressvpn
developed a technology called trusted
server that makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your info
I've been using Express VPN for a really
long time my internet speeds are always
blazing fast as well even when I connect
to servers thousands of miles away I can
still stream HD quality video with zero
lag not only that expressvpn is really
easy to use you'd install it on your
computer I mean even your grandparents
could use it if I err it up it's good to
go protect yourself with the VPN that I
use and trust use my link and expressvpn
comm slash Ben today get an extra three
months for free on a one-year package
that's expressive VPN calm slash Ben
visit expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn
more Ross thanks so much for stopping by
I really appreciate it thanks for having
me it's great to be here braving the
coronavirus epidemic and everything your
life I've you know I've been on book
tour so I've been flying not all over
the country but DC Washington LA so I
feel like I'm a potential super spreader
and everywhere I go I just give people
fist bumps and try and contain the
spread of the virus in my own way I
definitely appreciate that so your new
book is the decadent society how we
became the victims of our own success I
want to get to that book there's a lot
in there it's a really deep and
interesting book but let's start at the
obvious question what's it like to be a
conservative working at the New York
Times
I mean it's terrific I I get the chance
to write for people who disagree with me
right and that's
isn't that what every op-ed columnist
wants you're trying to change minds
persuade people and I get to do it twice
a week and as you can tell I'm
persuading people I've changed mine it's
right just just in my time at the New
York Times American liberalism has moved
rapidly towards becoming anti-abortion
you know towards skepticism of big
government I've had an immense impact
I'm very proud of myself but no I mean
that's I'm obviously kidding about the
second part but I do think it's an it's
a gift to get to write for a newspaper
that does you know as the stereotype
suggests but they're correct our
audience is predominantly liberal and
sometimes it's a little stressful and
exhausting and I get you know dragged on
Twitter's everyone does from time to
time but you know the times in general I
think I've been there for 10 years 11
years I've been there for a long time
amazingly and I think sometimes you know
I'll get questions from conservatives
like you know did they hang you in a
birdcage in the office and Pelt you with
rotting fruit and so on and in fact my
experience of working there and being
edited there has always been excellent
and you know to the extent that sort of
I watch what I say it's not because
anyone's looking over my shoulder it's
just because I'm sort of aware that I am
writing for people I disagree with and
I'm trying to be as persuasive as
possible so in that context what do you
make of a lot of the conservative
critiques of these so-called mainstream
media the accusations that places like
The Times are our wildly biased to the
left or as president Trump puts the
failing New York Times in a now it's
fake news how do you deal with that
being sort of inside the house there I
mean I think that you know the basic
conservative critique of the mainstream
media is right in the sense that the
media has a you know institutions elite
newspapers are primarily staffed by
people who vote for Democratic
politicians and candidates and it's not
a conspiracy it's just the function of
the fact that journalism has become an
upper-middle class you know elite
college-educated profession and people
who come out of those colleges as you
know I did once upon a time tend to
be overwhelmingly liberal and then there
are also some other I think sort of
psychological reasons why the kind of
sort of mental makeup that a lot of
reporters have biases them maybe a
little bit against sort of
traditionalism and towards an ideology
of sort of newness novelty progressivism
and so on but but yeah I mean that is
that's just a reality that inevitably I
think informs the way that the news gets
made and I think people at places like
The Times and you know the Washington
Post and Politico and so on are aware of
that and you know there is an actual
attempt to sort of try and correct for
those biases and it just doesn't always
work right so you know I'll read things
in my own paper that I feel like are
inflected with too much liberal bias
that obviously happens at the same time
what I say to conservatives is you know
you don't have to like the editorials
that the New York Times runs you're
obviously going to disagree with most of
them and you're gonna see sort of you
know things that seem like bias creep in
but there are things the New York Times
does that nobody else does this and
especially in an era when most
newspapers have shrunk or declined
nobody covers sort of the breadth of the
news national and international the way
The Times does nobody you know we're
talking about the coronavirus nobody has
been covering what's been going on in
China you know long before it came here
like the time stuffs nobody has the
resources nobody has the talent nobody
has the reporters and I think for
conservatives who are interested in sort
of you know encountering the world as it
actually is the you know the biases that
creep into mainstream media coverage are
not a reason not to read the times you
just have to be aware that you know that
isn't maybe the only newspaper that you
should read I mean if you should
certainly read it that's of the same
take I mean I do tell people they should
read the New York Times they should just
understand that what they're reading is
going to be inflected in a particular
way I'm not gonna make you answer for
all the decisions of the Editorial Board
of the New York Times obviously I think
one of the I appreciate it I mean one of
the great critiques obviously have sort
of the editorial board at least on the
bad page is that even among the
conservative wing on the on the op-ed
page and this is true for virtually all
the mainstream newspapers it's hard to
find a single person who either did vote
for President Trump or plans to vote for
President Trump in 2020 why why do you
think it's so hard I mean 50 percent of
the population presumably around that
around that number will vote for Trump
or voted for Trump last time why is it
so hard to find people to write for
op-ed pages who voted for him or plan to
vote for him next time I mean I think
part of it is just that and you know
this even better than I do right that
there was intense resistance to Trump in
especially I'd say the print portion of
conservative journalism so it wasn't
that you know The Times in the
Washington Post and so on sent out to
hire a bunch of conservative columnist
who would be squishy never Trump errs
right I mean someone like George Will
who's you know far more anti Trump in
certain ways than I am was considered
like a rock riff sort of defining figure
of the conservative movement until Trump
came along so the reaction to Trump in
that sense isn't just a function of who
the New York Times hires it's a function
of the fact that a lot of people some of
the you know best and smartest writers
on the right the places like National
Review and the now-defunct Weekly
Standard and people like you yourself
had strongly negative reactions to Trump
and that has sort of then carried over
into you know who's sort of who's sort
of on staff and who's writing about
Trump as his presidency perceives now I
will say that the times you know I'd say
we have myself and Bret Stevens and
David Burke's are sort of three
right-of-center sort of permanent
colonists but we also have as
contributing columnist both Chris
Caldwell and Dan McCarthy who are in
certain ways Pro Trump and have ended up
writing more for us since Trump was
elected and I do think there's a
consciousness at The Times The Times
does run pro Trump pieces I think
there's there's a balance between
figuring out how do you get voices on
the page who you know do represent the
breadth of American opinion and the 46
percent of America that voted for Trump
but also not just you know
saying well we need to sort of hire
someone to fill a quota if the
conservative calms we already hired
don't like the president enough but I
think it's you know I did I did Ben
Domenech is you know the publisher of
The Federalist I did his his radio hour
as part of this book tour and every time
I'm on his show he gives me like a 10
minute harangue about The Times's
failure to have to have approached from
calmness so it's I'm I'm aware of it so
what do you personally make up from here
an opinion columnist obviously so we're
now three and a half years into the
Trump presidency you know front from
where I sit as you mentioned I didn't
support Trump in 2016 I didn't vote for
either the candidates in 2016 he's been
significantly more conservative on
policy than I for one thought he would
be a lot of my fears about what he would
be have come true some of them have been
I think a little bit were overstated in
terms of the durability of institutions
has been pretty good with regard to
hemming in Trump's ability to break
those institutions but some of my fears
about you know the corseting of American
politics or the or the driving away of
young voters from the Republican Party
or the Republican Party centralizing
around some of the worst instincts that
Trump has I think that stuff has come
true with that said I plan on voting for
him specifically because this is a new
reality meaning the status quo itself
has changed we are not where we were in
2015 or 2016 when we had hoped to
foreclose these particular things from
happening now the things have happened
all of that is now baked into the new
reality and so now the question becomes
do I think the country gets better with
Trump continuing to push conservative
policy but being Trump or do I think he
gets better for some reason by electing
a Democrat would that actually improve
the state of the country so that sort of
my logic where are you on on President
Trump so I agree with you in part in
that I mean my biggest concern about
Trump was actually less ideological
because I'm probably a little more
sympathetic to some of his sort of
populist heresies and heterodox ease
then then you are so I was always you
know mildly comfortable with the idea of
a more populist president I was morally
uncomfortable with you know Trump's
morals right but then I also had this
basic fear that his level of competence
was too low to execute the office right
and so and that the world would
react to this kind of level of
unpreparedness in the American president
with a series of sort of tests crises
and calamities and that was something
that you know for the first few years of
his presidency I think I mostly got
wrong I thought the stock market would
go down like my calling Paul Krugman
famously predicted it did not
I thought figures like Vladimir Putin
would be more aggressive in pushing at
Trump and there's been some testing but
in general in spite of a lot of stumbles
I think Trump E and foreign policy has
you know the world has been more self
stabilizing than I thought and Trump has
made some decisions that I agree with so
in that sense I get in a lot of
arguments with people who like you have
sort of shifted and are probably going
to vote for him next time where they say
well Ross since you were you know wrong
about that shouldn't you come around and
right now my answer is sort of
conditioned on the fact that you know
were kind of living with the coronavirus
through the kind of moment that I feared
right and you know I'm not sure where
the story will be once this airs so I
don't want to be too speculative but I
will say that Trump made a really good
decision when the outbreak started in
China sort of against sort of the weight
of conventional liberal opinion to have
a travel ban and to sort of you know try
and maintain some kind of quarantine the
US border but it was always clear that
that wasn't going to be enough and Trump
basically bought the u.s. a month and
then as far as I can tell did nothing
with it and there's just been a lot of
really incompetent execution in the
White House in the face of you know a
crisis that could kill thousands and
thousands of people you know push us
into recession and so on so my concern
with the logic of you know I didn't vote
for him last time and hasn't been as bad
as I thought let's go again is that you
could make the opposite argument and say
okay we gambled on Trump and we won he
wasn't as bad as we thought the economy
boomed he appointed two Supreme Court
justices were no longer in danger of
having this big progressive swing on the
court and now we're playing with house
money and maybe and you know there comes
a moment when you may
a series of Gamble's on a guy who you
know has some qualities that don't make
him an ideal president where you want to
take your chips and leave the table and
say you know at some point a Democrat is
going to be elected again better four
years of Joe Biden now and a Republican
Party that can define itself pretty
effectively against him for the future
then let's see what four more years of
Trump bring you know I mean I lived
through as you did obviously the George
W Bush presidency right where you had a
series and Bush was a much more
competent and engaged president by far
than Donald Trump and yet you know from
the Iraq war to Katrina to finally the
financial crisis you had a series of
rolling calamities that wiped out the
Republican Party gave us the sort of big
liberal wave of the Obama era and I
think culturally to had a big effect on
sort of the culture swing to the left
and that's harder to prove but I I think
it's right and so my fear for a second
Trump turn this term is basically a
version of that that conservatives say
we gambled in one now we can feel safe
doing it again and then you'll get the
actual role in calamities and at the end
we'll look back and say wouldn't have
been the worst thing to have you know
John Kerry is our foil for four years
and our you know our best young
politicians getting ready to run against
him instead so with all of that said
would your logic change if Bernie
Sanders had been the nominee so it's
pretty obvious when we're filming this
that Bernie Sanders will not be the
nominee Joe Biden basically because in
my view people actually want for one
moment in time actually looked at Bernie
Sanders it was one thing when he was off
to the side he was just shouting at the
moon and he could be like okay well this
is kind of fun let's let's do that thing
at the moment he kind of entered into
the center of American politics and it
was clear that he might be the nominee
that even the Democratic Party looks at
this and when this is not a thing and
they shifted back to the senile he's
senile near octogenarian who can't
string together her sentence
he's obviously less threatening I mean
Biden is less threatening for the
country I think it's a very good thing
that Joe Biden wins the Democratic
nomination and not Bernie Sanders namely
because I think it would be horrible for
the country if half of the country had
had to centralize around an
anti-american communist it's much better
for them to centralize around they don't
like Trump and here's just an old
politician who's been an old politician
since he was 29 so
the logic that you're speaking makes a
certain amount of sense versus Biden
who's basically a status quo kanzen it
wouldn't have changed radically if
Bernie Sanders had been the candidate I
go back and forth on that right so on
the one hand obviously Sanders is from
any conservative perspective more
ideologically threatening than Biden at
the same time there are ways in which
because Sanders is an ideological
outlier and he would you know he
probably wouldn't carry lots of down
ballot races with him he Democrats would
be less likely to win the Senate you
could imagine Sanders being actually a
much weaker president even than didin
and I I expect Biden to be a pretty weak
president too and oddly I mean I think
from and this is you know goes back to
our mild disagreements but I think if
you're a populist conservative a Biden
presidency is better for you because
Biden is like mr. status quo you know
mister returned to the Obama era you
know mr. making deals with China
mr. soft corruption and his family and
it lets the sort of the people who want
to continue some form of trumpism sort
of pivot off that but if i'm ben shapiro
and i want the party to sort of swing
back a little more towards Reaganism and
limited government then actually a
Sanders presidency is the better soil in
certain ways and I think there's an
argument for Schapiro ISM right that
that a weak and constrained socialist in
the white house is actually what you
would need to get the Republican Party
back where you want it to go I mean I
think that that argument exists my fear
is that just for the country would be
listen I'd make I'd mint money if it's
Bernie Sanders for president but you
would literally build your own mint this
is your act I mean I would be stocking
up got like the whole deal but but with
that said the great fear of course is
that for the Republican party you always
center around the person who is the head
of the party and that becomes so I yes
there would be a better foil for
Republicans to work off of but that foil
would also now represent the heart and
soul of the Democratic Party in a way
that it's not clear that that full-on
anti-american socialism does at this
point I don't think the Joe Biden
knee-jerk dislike Americanism in the
same way that that Bernie Sanders does I
think Bernie Sanders is basically an old
communist fellow-traveller and he has
yet to identify a thing that American
foreign policy has done right he's
Howard Zinn just alive and Joe Biden is
basically you know a softer version of
Barack Obama but dead
yeah I mean Sanders in foreign policy
would be that's what frightened me
honestly you would yeah you've mesopause
he wasn't gonna get you would you would
get a more sort of withdrawal list
approach to foreign affairs you would
get a little more moralism in the sense
that sander because you know there isn't
a I mean if you want weirdly the most
Pro communist figure in the Democratic
field in terms of what communism is now
was Michael Bloomberg who couldn't find
a bad thing to say about the policy
right so if you get Sanders in you know
Sanders would talk a probably more than
Trump about human rights of FISA V
Russia and China but he would also give
Russia and China more space to maneuver
on the global stage
so in a second I want to get into what
you've described heroism versus maybe
now that ISM well there's no doubt that
ISM I'm just you know well I'm a neutral
father for a second but first let's talk
about the reality of life it's pretty
unpredictable who could have predicted
anything that's going on right now say
like four months ago one thing you
definitely can't predict is the path of
your future life which means that you
need life insurance if you are a
responsible human being policy genius
will help you get the life insurance
that you need by competitively pricing
the life insurance policies out there
and helping you find the very best life
insurance for the best possible price
policy genius we'll compare quotes from
the top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price this doesn't just
have a lot of leg work you could say
1500 bucks or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free
they're in contact with the life
insurance companies every day monitoring
developments helping customers navigate
every single step so if you're one of
the many people looking to buy life
insurance right now but you're not sure
where to start head on over to policy
genius calm policy genius will find you
the best rate handle the process
completely you can stop worrying about
life insurance and go do something fun
instead go check them out right now a
policy genius
all righty so let's talk a little bit
about the sort of populist conservatism
versus non populist conservatism battle
because this is really I think the most
interesting battle inside the Republican
Party and it's been sort of papered over
to a certain extent by the Trump victory
I think it was gonna break out into the
open of trumpet lost but it was is
really interesting because it this has
long roots obviously you've been writing
about this for a long time you're
writing with reihan Salam about a more
interventionist sort of conservative
view of government that shares some
features of bushier a compassionate
conservatism in some ways I grew up
opposing a lot of that opposing the
compassionate conservative label because
in my view markets are not
uncompassionate but maybe you can spell
out what you think conservatism should
look like because it's been articulated
in a bunch of different ways I've heard
sort of the Lockean versus Burkean
argument the idea being the John Locke
is is government is there only to
protect fundamental rights and birth
being government is there to protect a
traditional culture that leads to the
the rights arising I've heard this the
sort of quirky an argument that
conservatism is more an attitude than a
set of policy prescriptions or even a
philosophy and and but how would you
describe sort of the the conservatism
that you'd like to see I mean I guess
I'd frame it this way right which is
that that conservatives should support
free markets because free markets are
efficiency in growth maximizing
structures but free markets are not
always maximizing for every human good
and I think there are certain social
goods in American life that over the
last 50 years as cultural conservatives
have been arguing for a while have
started to crumble
meaning that you know sort of the
two-parent family is in decline
religionists and decline sort of social
engagement and community joining and so
on all these things are in decline and
on the one hand there are limits
obviously to what government can do
government can't start a religious
revival government can't make you love
your wife and so on but there are also
ways in which globalization and changes
that have been in certain ways
efficiency maximizing for the world but
not necessarily for
like middle to working-class America
have weakened the economic structures
that are underneath sort of the ability
of like you know somebody to raise three
kids on a single income right and there
and so my view basically going back as
you said to the Bush era is that there
are things that you can do with the
design of you know tax policy in the
welfare state that we have now and so on
that can build a somewhat firmer
structure under those sort of cultural
and communal institutions and so you
know my primary interest which is you
know not identical to where all of the
populace go has always just been family
policy and basically the view that you
know everything in everything in Western
life has gotten more efficient in
certain ways except taking care of and
raising kids right there's no like
labor-saving device except maybe you
know maybe a iPad to give the kid on a
plane right that makes it easier to
raise kids and that means that the costs
of raising kids have actually gone up in
various ways over the last thirty years
and there and and birth rates have
obviously gone way down and including in
the US over the last ten years this is
something that wasn't true
back in the early mid-2000s in the bush
compassion conservative area you could
still say that America was a birth rate
outlier and now it's not so with all of
that in mind I basically support using
government power to do more to support
families and that can take the form of
tax credits it can take the form of
child allowances I'm basically in favor
of proposals that are totally neutral
between working parents and stay-at-home
parents so I'm against the sort of I'm
very against universal daycare and pre-k
I think there's room probably for a
little more family leave policy but
mostly I just want to give families of
young children more money so that sort
of my that's my version of the larger
populist thing but then there are
obviously you know whether it's someone
like Oren Cass or Tucker Carlson most
famously who you know argue that we
should go beyond this and basically have
a kind of industrial policy that
focuses on building up American
industries and I'm not all the way with
all those ideas I do think though that
there are reasonable points again for
particularly in the context of like the
coronavirus thing right where you know
the sort of pure free market view says
well look the most efficient thing is to
have all of our factories in China
because that maximizes our GDP and
maximizes China's GDP and we all get
rich together but there are also some
reasons why it's not good to export your
entire industrial base to China when
China is one ruled by a you know a mix
of communist and fascist dictatorship
and to China is totally vulnerable to
things like this pandemic where suddenly
you can have a shutdown in the global
supply chain and we can't even
manufacture you know the n95 masks that
you're supposed to put on your faces so
that has made me I'm a little bit
agnostic about the Industrial Policy
stuff but the coronavirus thing has made
me a little more open to the idea that
again public policy should say look
there's a national security interest in
not totally d-- industrializing the
United States again even if in global
terms that's not the perfect efficiency
maximizing perspective yeah I guess
that's doubted ISM to the extent that it
exists I mean the the the strongest case
obviously you know with regard to not
investing in China is in fact not in
direct conflict with the with the sort
of long-term free-market case meaning
that if you're fostering the growth of a
communist regime that exploits labor and
right and that is actually not helping
the free market you're actually propping
up a massive government infrastructure
that is repressing billion people but is
it but it's something that I agree with
I want to go back and examine a couple
of the premises that we're talking about
here so when you first said you support
the free market then you're the the
rationale for supporting free markets
was a utilitarian one he said the free
markets are efficient they're they're
excellent to building prosperity folks
like me I've suggested that free markets
are not just good in that they are
utilitarian free markets are good and
that they're inherently moral meaning
that you own property as an individual
human being that is it's a lock-in
argument essentially that as an
individual you have a right to the
property that you create that people do
not have a right to take that away from
you in the name
of broader communal interest and that
the the general notion of being able to
violate somebody's consent because you
have higher priorities through a simple
majority mean vote is a violation of
individual rights my great fear with
sort of arguing for the market
utilitarian terms is that you're correct
in the sense that you can always argue
different forms of utilitarianism what's
more utilitarian a higher GDP or more
working families if you if you believe
that the market is working in direct
opposition to that which I'm gonna get
to in a second I'm not sure that that's
the case yes it but what what do you
make of the moral argument for markets
because I'm some people say they're
there to cheers for the free market kind
of people I will count myself in the
three cheers for the free market person
I just think that the market doesn't do
everything that people wanted to do the
market isn't the the end of the human
need markets are great at what markets
are supposed to do allowing me to keep
what I build and alienate that which I
build and alienate my own labor allowing
me to create more prosperity and then
there's an entire other side of human
life which is the spiritual need which
is not going to be filled by materialism
no matter what you do and that leads to
sort of the second question I don't mean
to dump all the questions at once but I
can answer them all it leads to the
second question which is you know the
the sort of common good conservatism has
suggested that it's the markets that
have worked in opposition to family that
is driven child rates down childbearing
rates down that has broken up families
I'd suggest that government intervention
is him over that same period has been
extraordinary that the government is far
larger now than it was in the 1930s 40s
and 50s when family structures were far
more intact that the welfare state
there's a solid case we made that it had
horrific impacts particularly on black
families and that the the problem here
is trying to solve a cultural problem
namely the decline of religion with a
government infrastructure that is not
designed to fill that gap so I mean yeah
I am more of a - cheers for capitalism
guy which doesn't mean that I reject the
moral case that you make it's more that
I think that in you know in the real
world it can be hard to separate
separate out the forms of capitalism
where you know you are achieving
something that is sort of your personal
achievement alone and where you are
embedded in structures that make
that kind of achievement you know less I
mean this and this is gonna sound you
know a touch like the you didn't build
that a little foreign stuff right which
is which is and I think there there are
bad things about those arguments but
what's bad about those arguments is that
they discourage people from being
entrepreneurial but it is good for
people to believe that they can build
something and it's something that they
have an ownership stake in and they do
right and you know human creativity is
an incredibly important part of all of
the great things that capitalism has
done that being said like if you you
know inherit five million dollars from
your father right it's not clear how
that fits into the Lockean paradigm
exactly of you know that you deserve
everything you earn and so on and
similarly and this is something that
libertarians don't disagree with it all
right but the structures of crony
capitalism and the linkages between
government and business and so on make
it if you're looking at a given society
it's not always easy to say he deserved
that she didn't deserve that it you know
it there's there's a mixture going on
and that's been true from the beginning
of capitalism right that like the free
market is something that has always been
structured in part by government
decisions and government interventions
and so on going back to you know in the
u.s. back to the public improvement
programs in the nineteenth century and
you know in the case of Europe going
back even further than that and I guess
that reality I think makes me
comfortable balancing sort of your moral
argument and saying yes that's true we
want a society where people think it is
you know moral to build and keep what
you build but also say you know that we
can have a certain amount of
redistribution because we can't quite
see where perfect justice lies and so
you want to have some you know some sort
of baseline where you're not letting
people fall below certain floors and
then you also want to recognize that
while markets you know well there is a
moral case for markets they do in some
cases select for efficiency rather than
sort of
perfectly shared human flourishing right
so like I agree with you right that you
know the free market did not destroy the
American family right and I and I'm a
cultural conservative because I think
that the cultural story matters more
than the economic story and I've had
plenty of arguments with liberals where
I'll say you know if you know if you
look at the timeline of you know divorce
rates and these different things it's
not deindustrialization that did it
that sort of the cultural revolutions of
the 60s mattered more that being said
it's also the case that that you know
this shift from an industrial to an
information era economy has been very
rewarding for highly educated Americans
and less rewarding for people who would
have done better in the industrial
economy and that's not of sort of moral
failing on the part of factory workers
who just need to you know learn to code
right or something and so you know there
when something like that happens there's
room for policy makers to say how can we
one preserve the utilitarian gains or
the utilitarian advantage of the free
market to avoid creating a society where
people don't accept the moral case that
people should be able to be
entrepreneurial and keep what they build
but also figure out how to avoid ending
up in a country where you have a sort of
depopulated drug-addicted hinterland and
you know the sort of rich urban city is
where everyone has college degrees and
is clustering but no one can afford to
live there because then and nobody has
kids right and there are libertarian
responses to that right that are but
that are sort of reasonable you know
sort of build more housing stock right I
mean it's not I think there is a version
of libertarian populism that would
accomplish some of the policy goals that
I want to achieve and some of the people
I think some of the people like Tucker
and others you know when they talk about
like well the rising cost of medical
care or the rising cost of education and
so on there are libertarian policy
proposals that would help reduce those
costs and make things easier for
families but yeah I'm also I'm also
perfectly comfortable you know as was
Friedrich Hayek right
like with the idea of a certain amount
of redistribution a lot of the original
sort of founding fathers of libertarian
conservatism were not sort of Full Tilt
boogie Einar and ian's they said you
know we need a certain a certain amount
of we need a certain kind of welfare
state to sort of maintain people's
commitment to capitalism in certain ways
and I think that's right and I think you
know at various points in time you want
to redesign the welfare state you have I
mean just to take one very small example
right so in the 1990s you know you
mentioned the perverse effect that
anti-poverty programs had on family
formation on you know encouraging teen
pregnancy and so on that was sort of the
conservative argument in the 80s and 90s
and conservatives along with Bill
Clinton passed welfare reform and lo and
behold teen pregnancy went down and
liberals don't think that the welfare
reform led teen pregnancy to go down but
I think it was probably one factor and
that was a conservative policy victory
but here we are now 25 years later and
our chat our social challenge isn't a
skyrocketing teen pregnancy rate it's
the fact that people aren't getting
married and aren't having kids at all
and in that situation I'm worried less
about you know the perverse incentives
of spending you know if you spend a
little more money on families maybe some
people are more irresponsible with what
they do with that money I'm less worried
about that in this moment than I would
have been 25 years ago and I'm more of
the view that you know if you encourage
people to have more kids you know I'd
rather have a society where there were a
few more out of wedlock births if we
were getting the birth rate up generally
so you want I'm just I think you want to
be adaptive in the way you apply
conservative policy and I think what's
good about the populace you know
allowing for errors and so on is that
they are trying to be adaptive they're
saying well why did Donald Trump get
elected like how did that happen why
didn't Ted Cruz's arguments carry the
day with Republican voters well let's
take our voters seriously and you know
look at things that went wrong let's
look at things we've predicted that
where we were wrong about where we
thought that you know opening trade with
China would you know produce many more
winners than losers and in fact it
produced some real concentrated job
losses you know what can
policy to do about that so I think
there's room for that without you know
casting Adam Smith and John Locke into
the outer darkness tonight so in a
second ona ask you about the differences
in in culture versus sort of government
policy but first let's talk about the
fact that you are spending tons of time
with your kids these days this means
that you are not getting the kind of
sleep that you need I can tell you I
mean my level of stress with my kids
really high right now but when I lay my
head down on my helix sleep mattress I
am good to go because he looks sleek
made a mattress just for me helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete they will match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper or hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or a bed with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine and CNN called the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep comm slash
button take their two minutes sleep
quizzes they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
ten year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights at risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but I promise you will it really is a
fantastic fantastic mattress helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 200 soph at helix sleep comm slash
Ben that is helix sleep comm slash Ben
check them out helix sleep comm slash
Ben get up to $200 off for a mattress
made just for you helix sleep comm slash
man and get up to 200 bucks off so let's
talk for a second about the differences
between sort of culture and economics
and what they can do so one of the
reasons that I can afford to be quite
libertarian about you know what I think
government ought to do is the first
there's the affirmative argument which
is that I'm very much afraid that
there's not a limiting principle to
government should do X to support
families and government should just do X
period meaning that that assumes that
the right people are in control
government and my basic assumption about
government is that somebody who I don't
like is gonna be in control of us in
mechanisms five minutes from now and
using them against me and so my comfort
level really exists particularly the
federal level at the government should
not be able to do many of the things
that the government is doing and that
the gap needs to be filled really at the
local level where you have much more
agreement I'm much more willing to in my
local community where I know everybody
pay taxes for redistribution to people
that I know and who go to my synagogue
then right I am for people who I country
I don't know them I don't know
of Asians are I don't know what their
living arrangements are whether I
approve of them
I mean Church used to fill this gap in
other words the these more libertarian
orientation of American government that
existed for most of the early history of
the Republic that was predicated upon
the existence of a virtuous citizenry
that was going to be organized
basically by church and the church was
going to fill that gap as churches waned
the and this is what I think government
has replaced churches as as government
has grown torches waned government has
been fulfilling the the supportive
nature that church once played the sort
of argument that Tim Carney makes yeah
and that as that happens church has
declined and they have a perverse cycle
or Church declines there's more need
government steps in even more there's
more need government steps in even more
and then there's no limiting principle
at all so this is really two questions
one is can these institutional problems
even be solved by government of which
I'm quite skeptical and two is that if
they even if they can would it be better
or two to try and solve these problems
on a cultural level so to take an
example if you're talking about giving
certain tax credits to people for having
children I don't know very many people
who think about the tax credit they're
gonna get when they have kids most
people in a prosperous society recognize
that kids are more of a net drain on
your resources than our net benefit to
your resources no matter what you do I
mean they cost a lot of money the Rutan
the prosperous countries don't have as
many kids because when you're poor you
need kids for your labor force and when
you're prosperous they cost you hundreds
of thousands of dollars and so why would
you bother with that when you could
spend that hundreds of thousands of
dollars vacationing or doing whatever it
is that you want to do I'm not sure that
that's a problem that is is curable by a
simple tax credit the reason that I mean
your religious Imanol is just the reason
that I have kids because I think there's
a moral injunction to have kids that it
makes the world a better place to have
children and that I have a religious
obligation to have kids as that wanes
I'm not sure that that simply saying to
somebody here's a here's four thousand
bucks extra a year for your kid who's
gonna cost you five but that's really
gonna solve the problem one I totally
agree that there is you know there's a
basic limitation to what public policy
can do to reshape culture and you know
to the extent that there is sort of a
ultimate cultural solution an ultimate
solution to a lot of the problems
you and I agree face America it has to
come from cultural and religious revival
and government can't like will that into
being that said I do think people make
decisions on the margins about whether
to have kids with financial concerns in
mind and so it's not that you know a
couple who are enjoying their lives
going backpacking and going on cruises
and so on are gonna say oh I get this
you know four thousand dollar tax credit
I guess we'll you know become
pronatalist and you know convert to
Orthodox Judaism right and and start
having kids that's not how it works but
there are lots of families that I sort
of do end up deciding between having two
or three kids or having three or four
kids and when they make those decisions
finances definitely enters into it so if
you say you know well this kid is gonna
cost me ten thousand dollars a year but
you know I know that you know because of
a tax credit or some other public
program it's actually only gonna cost me
five I do think that makes a difference
on the margin and there's a fair amount
of research on this demographer named
Lyman stone who's a Lutheran missionary
in Hong Kong has written a lot about how
these different programs work and some
of them don't work at all and some of
them are badly designed some of them
seem to work on the margins you can have
some kind of effect on family formation
and birth rates if you're willing to you
know put enough money towards it which I
guess I am I am willing to do on the on
the philosophical point so I think the
problem the problem there is that it's
we're not sitting here you know in
nineteen twenty before the New Deal
happened or in nineteen fifty five
before the Great Society happened having
an argument about whether a broad-based
federal bureaucracy and a whole welter
of programs should exist we're having an
argument in a world where the
administrative state and all it's sort
of colonies has existed in some form for
almost a hundred years and the problem
for conservatives who say well it
shouldn't exist because I want there to
be a limiting principle is that you're
only limiting yourself right I mean
that's I think that's what you know the
if Saurabh Amari were sitting here
talking to you and I'll try and channel
him he would say
all you're doing in this case is for
philosophical reasons tying one hand
behind your back and saying well I don't
want the other party to get in power and
have these powers but the other party
has those powers and he's using them
when they're in power right when when a
liberal administration is in power it
does not hesitate to sort of you know
find the intersections of government
power and cultural power as you know the
Obama administration did for instance
all the time in its second term in the
creative ways it used title nine and so
on
to push private universities to do
things and push state governments to do
things that advanced various forms of
the progressive agenda that's just
reality and I think the problem for
social conservatives especially is that
if if you just say we want there to be a
limiting principle so when we're in
power we're not going to push hard for
things that we think help you know our
vision of the good society what happens
that with Republicans is not that
Republican politicians say oh that's
great we're gonna have an austere
libertarianism and Justin Amash you know
will set the agenda Republicans say okay
well we've got some business groups over
here that are very happy to take federal
money and you just get under Republican
to sort of ill thought-out crony
capitalism and you end up with a
republican party that has the rhetoric
of libertarianism and the reality of
sort of just serving business interests
and this is sort of my attempt to bridge
the gap between populist and
libertarians the populist say the
libertarians control everything and free
market fundamentalism rules the
Republican Party and the libertarians
say what are you talking about when the
Republican Party's in power it does
crony capitalism but both of those
things are true the rhetorical frame of
the party has been libertarian but then
once in power it you know there's it
just sort of spends money on business
clients and tends to ignore families and
sort of culturally conservative clients
and I I'm just not sure that the very
principled approach that you take has
ultimately served conservatives well in
the culture war which again doesn't mean
that I have a ten-point plan for you
know here's everything the Federal
Bureau
she should do to advance conservative
goals but you know in the case of the
Trump administration even things like
you know their their attempt to raise
taxes on university endowments right or
Trump's these sort of still being
considered attempt to shift you know how
federal architecture gets done right and
I don't think I imagine that's something
you submit sexual thing for sure I was
right but so I think there are creative
ways for cultural conservatives in power
to think you know a little bit how do we
weaken institutions that are our foes
and strengthen groups and cultural
forces that are our friends and it
doesn't have to take the form of you
know spending a ton of money on
something but it it does require a
certain creativity about the uses of
power and I think where I agree with the
populist says I don't think social
conservatives have thought us creatively
as they should about the uses of power
the countervailing point of view would
come from sort of a utilitarian place
meaning I'm a social conservative er I
wrote a book my second book was all
about the the evils of pornography and
why there should be significant
regulation on we were you were way ahead
of this is I was 20 at the time 21 so
it's been a while but with that said one
of the concerns that I have is that it
seems to me that a lot of the populist
conservatives particularly some of the
social conservatives with whom I totally
agree on principle that they're
operating from a premise which is that
we are at a nice edge on a lot of these
issues when I think that in many cases
the issue has basically been lost not
only at the legal level but at the
cultural level and so arguing that the
government should be used in order to do
X that I like that well I may like that
well that may be nice why l've left may
do exactly the reverse to me if it's
just a question of whose ox is being
gored the the reality is that my ox is
likely to be gored a lot more often than
the other guys ox is likely to be gored
and not only that if the country
basically just becomes a raw battle
between two competing poles of power who
are just going to Gore each other that
the country actually doesn't have a
future that there's no way for us to
live together because at a certain point
one of those groups is going to become
the permanent minority and then the
question is going to become well why do
I stay in a country with these other
group
or cramming down their version of policy
on me when it's possible that
Republicans by taking the government out
of the equation in some cases actually
allowed more room for cultural
conservatism to thrive meaning that when
people don't feel threatened by cultural
conservatism and they don't feel the
cultural conservatism is going to come
along with the power of the government
gone and compel particular activity it's
easier to make a case like leave my
church alone and people say okay well
you're not trying to force anything on
me so I guess I'll leave your church
alone a little bit more than okay well
my church is really important to me and
it's so important that when we get power
we're going to reverse Weber's fell and
we're going to pass a federal marriage
amendment
right which is not going to happen yeah
and and I I agree that there is a
there's a certain over enthusiasm maybe
a good rival reaction about point that
I'm making it's sort of the same point
that you were making about Trump could
drive a reaction then pushes everybody
at the far left in the Democratic Party
the the the cultural conservative point
is if you say I'm going to use the
government to come after things that you
like and then they say okay well when we
get power so far we basically left the
churches alone but now we're gonna go
full bit or work we're moving all 501c3
status from every church that doesn't
satisfy our priorities on same-sex
marriage like that that that brings the
entire country virtually to the point of
open warfare I mean I famously said no
can't come take my kids it's not a thing
that I remember I remember that that got
some attention
yeah I mean I I think so I'm I'm pretty
sympathetic in certain ways to the case
for de-escalation and I wrote a lot
after obergefell about sort of you know
how how do we figure out pluralism right
how do we figure out a way for religious
conservatives to sort of be respected as
a minority in the society that has
changed and you know how do we how do we
live together in peace and so on I will
say that I didn't feel like I got a ton
of take up on those arguments from my
liberal friends and the I mean I think
part of what the social conservatives
are reacting against too is the speed
with which we went from you know
same-sex marriage doesn't affect your
marriage and it's just a sort of
expansion of right to you know
substantial you know what we're sending
substantial substantial infringement on
religious liberty and cost infringement
contemplated further you know we're
right or Roarke is like sort of doing
the full you know tax your churches and
take your guns kind of liberalism
although the fact that O'Rourke and
other candidates like him didn't
actually go anywhere in the end maybe is
a sign that that some kind of cultural
truce is more possible but no I go I go
back and forth I think there is
definitely there's definitely an
argument for cultural de-escalation that
is not where the sort of younger
religious conservatives are right now I
think the challenge for Republicans
though in sort of managing all this is
figuring out you know where they can
deliver actual victories to certain
religious conservatives to right because
if you say to religious conservatives
you know well we're never getting rid of
a berga fell you know we're never having
the federal marriage amendment or
anything like that
religious conservatives can say okay I
can live with that but you know what
I've given blood sweat and tears to get
justices on the Supreme Court and at
least they're gonna create more space
for abortion restrictions right and so
like this is sort of this is sort of the
unanswered question right now of the
Kavanagh appointment and sort of where
you know what where does the court end
up going on abortion right and if we go
through another five years where the
sort of Roberts and Kavanagh between
them sort of you know and best maybe
chip away a tiny bit at Roe I think
you're gonna have a lot of religious
conservatives who say why did we fight
so hard for Kavanagh while Susan Collins
was telling everyone he wouldn't
overturn Roe we're gonna impose firmer
litmus tests on judges that are more
ends based more outcomes based more like
what liberals impose so I think that's
sort of that's like a zone where you can
imagine I think religious conservatives
justifiably saying a terrible system has
not worked out well I mean that area I'm
in full sympathy I mean I think that
there should be plain plain litmus test
when it comes to Supreme Court justices
from the right I mean the left is not
shy about this but it's not even to the
left ain't shy about it I think that
originalism does lead to particular
results and one of those results that
bro is a bunch of crap and pretty much
everybody who has studied Rho is a legal
matter right left and center and is
honest about it recognizes that whether
you like the outcome or not
Rho has absolutely nothing to do with
the Constitution of the United States he
may like the outcome but like the the to
me that that's there are a lot of it was
one of the interesting things about sort
of the populace versus non populist
fight on the right is how much
miscommunication there is what I mean by
that is this is a perfect example I
don't think there are a lot of people
even on the libertarian right it would
be anti I mean aside from maybe people
who are overtly in favor of just
pro-choice mechanisms but if they're
honest about their legal analysis I
don't think there are that many people
on my side of the aisle who would say
there shouldn't be a litmus test on Roe
I think they're absolutely you should be
able to assess under over for judges I'm
not I'm not willing to to trust justices
with their vague articulations of
originalism I mean I was the only person
I know who came out against Roberts
before he was before he was actually
confirmed in 2005 because he didn't have
a track record I came out against
Cavanaugh I didn't have a track record
so I so I'm very much in favor of yeah
conservatives driving a hard bargain and
I don't think sorts of things right and
I think that's to a case where yeah I
don't think it's I don't think it's
mostly the sort of you know limited
government conservatives who are against
imposing litmus test it's more there
that they sort of you know the
institutional Republican Party is not
enthusiastic about overturning Roe and
that in turn creates sort of pressures
where it's easier for Republican
justices to give you know the federalist
society a little of what it wants on
Chevron deference so you know than it is
to go further on Roe although to be
honest even on even on the sort of
administrative state stuff I think
they're you know you may get less from
this court than some conservatives want
or expect so I do want to ask you about
where you think the Republican Party is
going post Trump but first let's talk
about how you can save money at the post
office right now number one don't go to
the post office number to go to stamps
calm because anything you can do at the
post office you can do at stamps calm
there
man postage means you can skip that trip
to the post office and save money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office here at Dailey where we've been
using stamps calm since 2017 no more
wasted time no more schlepping boxes
over to the post office
stamps calm brings all the services of
the US Postal Service direct to your
computer whether your small office
sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out products even a warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps con handles it all with ease you
can simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hanage your mail carrier or
drop it in a mailbox it's that simple
plus you get five cents off every first
class stamp up to 40% off shipping rates
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters
no equipment to lease no long-term
commitments this is a no brainer it's no
wonder 700,000 small businesses already
use stamps calm right now my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage UN's
digital scale no long term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that is stamps comm
enter Shapiro so post Trump where do you
think the party goes because that's
really what we're talking about here
because Trump has papered a lot of this
over with the rubric of just being anti
left and that may be sort of the future
of the Republican Party is you just
oppose the left and handout of tax cut
every so often but what hasn't that been
the Republican Party for most of our
lifetime in certain ways yeah it has and
I think that that that you could easily
see that accelerating but as we sort of
move presumably at some point into a
future where it's non-oxygen Ariens
running against each other where do you
think that the Republican Party does do
you think that it sort of perverts to
the social conservative populism that
you're talking about do you think it
moves in more libertarian direction
that's been sort of the great battle I
think yeah I mean I think that
so one as I said earlier I think a
Bernie Sanders presidency would probably
produce more of the libertarian swing
and the Joe Biden presidency would
produce more of a populist swing by
generally in sort of demographic terms
the Republican Party has less of a sort
of naturally low tax limited government
base than it used to and its coalition
consists of religious conservatives many
of whom are probably somewhere in
between the two of us on these issues
and then a lot of the sort of more
secular working-class
who were moving into the coalition
before Trump but that's obviously
accelerated so that means I think that
you know some form of populism is going
to be with us for a while and the
question is what form does it take right
and this is not a new thing I think that
every Republican president comes in and
ends up you know being a little more
activist and interventionist in
government policy than you would like
and so I think if I were if I had your
views I would be spending a lot of time
thinking you know what what's the least
bad form of activist government right is
it you know what george w bush did was
very focused on education and poverty
right and whereas what the populace now
want is more focused on family and
industrial policy so those are two
different ways of compromising your
libertarianism and it's you know since
politics is the art of compromise it's
worth thinking for more libertarian
conservatives it's worth thinking about
you know well what which of those is
better you know would I rather have
compassion of conservatism come again or
would I rather have Josh Holley and you
know his sort of like war on Silicon
Valley as as the thing in my party that
I don't love but I have to live with
let's talk about kind of the state of
the country overall because while we're
having this argument
are we just shifting around the deck
chairs on the Titanic a little bit so in
your book the decadent Society finally
gets a pitch here are we a decadent
Society so you give a definition of
decadence which suggests economic
stagnation and a certain level of
cultural stagnation I'm sympathetic to
the argument honestly more sympathetic
on the cultural stagnation than on the
economic stagnation I think there are a
lot of buried elements of statistics
that tend to suggest that lifestyle has
risen fairly dramatically actually over
the last three to four decades including
the amount of space that we live in I
think I want to definitely have bigger
houses bigger houses we have nicer
things we are working fewer hours on the
job than we ever have really and we were
spending more vacation time so those
were usually fairly good indicators of
an economy that's doing fairly well but
you're right that it's a less ambitious
economy and it feels like it is
bifurcating between sort of a
knowledge-based economy and people who
are maybe getting left behind and the so
called IQ and it's also an economy that
is floated on an
and here I'll I'll speak your language
it's floated on unprecedented deficit
spending yet right so it is true that
you know the growth that we had well two
things are true right first the US
economy has not collapsed it hasn't gone
you know and people have not been
eviscerated America is richer today than
it was in 1970s people do have bigger
houses there are sort of advantages to
the economy right now that being said
right now at this sort of you know pre
coronavirus peak of economic activity
we've got 2% growth with trillion-dollar
deficits and fifty years ago or even you
know briefly under Reagan and then
briefly again in the late 1990s we had
5% growth with either much lower
deficits or no deficits at all and so
that's when I talk about economic
decadence that's sort of what I'm
talking about it's not that we're
impoverished it's not that things
haven't improved on the margins it's
that we have become a rich society that
sort of pays ourselves to feel richer
then maybe we actually are and that
doesn't mean it's unsustainable I think
actually with you know low interest
rates and an aging population you can
carry these deficits longer than you
know the tea party thought in 2011 but
it doesn't mean that the it's still a
sign that the underlying structures of
the economy are not great and certainly
not what what they were under Eisenhower
or under Reagan or it's never great when
you're turning to the central bank is
your chief method of alright I don't
think the economy right exactly and you
can't that you the central bank spend
you know prints money and we never get
inflation which again suggests that
we're a long way from sort of being the
truly hot economies that we had under
Reagan and in the 50s and and I think
that's I mean my my basic view is that
we're not really decked chairs on the
Titanic because it's not I'm not sure
we're about to sink I think the issue is
is more that we are sort of stuck
basically and we still have
technological innovation but it's
concentrated heavily in Silicon Valley
heavily in communication and simulation
and we haven't achieved the things that
we expected we achieve in you know cost
of energy in transportation changes
in medicine we've made sort of grinding
progress against cancer but we haven't
had any of the leaps that we had with
penicillin and other things in the past
and and then we're getting older we're
happy you know we were talking before
we're having fewer kids people are you
know enjoying their vacations instead of
having the extra kid and that in turn
puts more it makes it puts more pressure
towards stagnation because societies get
older they're less entrepreneurial
they're less dynamic and they're you
know less averse to fundamental change
to any system so like a libertarian is
going to be very frustrated in this
society because there's this huge
barnacled bureaucratic welfare state
built up that nobody can actually reform
right so the big reforms are you know a
little bit of tinkering around the edges
under under Ronald Reagan and then Obama
sort of Jerry Riggs an extra arm on to
the whole system to give a few more
people health insurance but you don't
get sweeping programs of reform and I
think the the the danger where you know
it is that you then there was sort of a
a dystopian slide here right where if
all your progress is in your phones and
your video games and your technologies
of simulation and if politics isn't
responsive to movements and activists
you can't actually change anything and
if society is getting older then you
just can easily imagine a world where
the trends of the last ten years
continue where you have this retreat
into virtual life pornography you know
we legalize marijuana and give everybody
opioids and you sort of numb everything
down brave new world brave new world
exactly and you know I'm not saying
we're gonna be there in 50 years but I
think if you were saying Ravin the world
is not that bright in fact a horrible
place for the people living in brave new
world I'm very early going themselves
very comfortable you know right it's
like you know we need to do the Elon
Musk Joe Rogan thing where right I light
up a joint a joint or something but
therefore because it's not that bad
there's a lot of people for whom what in
the book I call sustainable decadence
becomes the best thing they can imagine
where it's just like all right
you know we thought we could go to the
moon but we can't go to the moon we
thought we could cure cancer but we
can't cure cancer but we're rich and
eliminate were stable we're living 82
years it's not so bad and they're right
it's not so bad but something
fundamental has been lost in American
society in the last 50 years and I think
this is something that Trump in his way
totally got right make America great
again was you know American ambition
right it was like a and and you know
Trump's best speech of his presidency
was his last State of the Union which
was basically him saying we beat
decadence and that wasn't true I hate 2%
growth does not be decadence but it was
I think it spoke to people's discontent
with this that people know that there
was an America that you can see if you
go watch at the Apollo 11 documentary
that came out last year you can see the
remains of it everywhere in Southern
California right this was like this was
like the future you know the future of
the entire world you can see it if you
watch Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood right like this culture that
was so young and filled with energy some
of it toxic and some of it terrible but
energy all the same but we don't know
how to get back to that and yeah and I
don't think there isn't I I don't think
you can get back to it without something
disjunctive happening and so the last
part of the book is me talking about the
various weird things that would have to
shift for us to get out of decadence and
some of those have to do is invention
you could imagine scientific
breakthroughs that take us out of our
phones and into some different world and
some of them have to do with politics
and political realignment and but
ultimately I think you and I agree on
this I think you know the sort of
despair of the late modern world has to
be answered ultimately by a recovery of
a sense of purpose a sense that the
human story is a story and that somebody
capital s somebody it is actually
telling it so that's my Catholic bias
but I don't think it's wrong I think the
the ennui of decadence is in part it
comes in from with a view that you know
we filled the
old weak space this too far away we
can't get to the moon we can't get to
Mars and God probably doesn't exist so
we're just stuck with ourselves forever
and only some combination of Elon Musk's
rockets and a religious revival can't
get us out of that I do want to ask you
a couple more questions about how we as
a country move past decadence how we do
that as a society but if you want to
hear Ross Douthat answers you have to be
a daily wire member to subscribe head on
over to daily wire comm and click
Subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation there be sure to pick up a
copy of Ross's new book the decadent
society it's available today on Amazon
Barnes & Noble anywhere you buy books
Ross thanks so much for stopping by this
was really fun and we're gonna do
rotavirus fist bottle revised fist bump